is morgan uncensored tonight a prime
time exclusive they were the shocking
comments that stunned the world
billionaire formula one founder bernie
ecclestone defending vladimir putin
i'd still take a bullet for him
i'd rather it didn't hurt but i'm if he
does i'll still take a bullet
because he's a first-class person
and
what he's doing is something that he
believed was the right thing he was
doing for russia
tonight one of the most controversial
men in world sport responds to the
scandal that's rippled across the world
after those words bernie ecclestone goes
one-on-one with me in an explosive
jaw-dropping interview in which he
attempts to explain what he said and why
he said it
[Music]
[Music]
well good evening welcome to piers
morgan uncensored tonight a gripping
incendiary interview with one of the
most powerful figures in the history of
world sport formula one founder bernie
ecclestone this weekend should have been
about the british grand prix at
silverstone one of the most prestigious
events of the year and the sport that he
created instead this weekend's racing
has been eclipsed by two explosive
scandals centered around one person him
first it emerged a former world champion
nelson piquet had racially abused
british superstar lewis hamilton
branding in the n-word several times in
a podcast
pk has now apologized but denied the
term he used was racist even though it
was racist
well astonishingly in an interview with
my old tv show good morning britain this
morning bernie eggleston defended pk
and then in comments which sparked a
global ferrari he then defended russian
dictator vladimir putin
tonight on uncensored and a prime time
exclusive bernie eagleton responds to
all the heat
when you say you don't think vladimir
putin meant to wage this war it just
sounds to me shockingly naive at best
i'm not trying to defend him in any
shape or form why would you say that you
would still take a bullet for vladimir
putin it's an expression when did you
last speak to him i'm not going to
answer that you're defending nelson
piquet for calling him the n word which
you say should be treated like somebody
calling you a bit undersized it's
terribly rude to say somebody's
underscore always a fat person you
genuinely think that there is some
equivalence between calling a black
person the m word and saying that you're
short if for example they're black and
they're saying or if you're fat i
suppose it's the same sort of feeling
it's not though is it what is your
response to what lewis hamilton said
bernie complete load of rubbish it's no
surprise to me bernie your comments this
morning calls outrage and i think when
people watch our interview they're going
to feel more outraged you're trying to
set me up
which you're not successful in doing
well echoes there's no under running
formula one but his comments matter he
wields massive global influence people
around the world pay attention to what
he says and after this interview i
suspect they'll be paying a lot more
attention
he's had the whole day to reflect on the
comments he made about president putin
this morning and about lewis hamilton
being called the n word i started by
asking if you stood by what he said
about the russian dictator
well i'm joined now by bernie ecclestone
bernie good evening to you
good evening to you
buddy i've known you a long time uh
you've never been one to hide your
thoughts you've always been a straight
talker but now you've had a few hours to
see how your comments about vladimir
putin and about nelson piquet and his
racist comments how they played out in
the public arena do you have any regrets
what i meant just wonder whether you
whether you regret the way you worded
some of the things you said
i forgot what i said actually
well okay i'll remind you you said that
whatever i said i meant
so
good or bad
well if let me remind you what you said
so you said about vladimir putin i would
i would still take a bullet for him i'd
rather it didn't hurt but i would still
take a bullet because he's a first-class
person and what is what he's doing is
something he believed was the right
thing
yeah i mean when i say i take a bullet i
mean i'm quite sure it's an expression
you couldn't have used
uh in your life
it's an expression
i'd stand behind it
i mean the problem with the thing
yeah sorry go on buddy
no he's he's a he's a
as far as i'm concerned he's a good guy
he's never done anything that i would
feel
he's not the right guy to be talking to
i mean you're perfectly entitled to your
view about putin from the dealings
you've had with him and obviously you
started the russian grand prix and i
understand that and you've had a lot of
dealings with him you're perfectly
entitled to that i think the problem
that people have with your comments
today bernie is that they are highly
inflammatory given that putin is
currently waging a monstrous illegal war
in ukraine slaughtering thousands of
innocent people who are literally
getting a bullet from vladimir putin
and i think that's terrible
i think when all this started it wasn't
what he thought was going to happen i
think he thought it was gonna be a four
day
sort of threat and then big discussions
and they'd get things sorted out
i don't think he believed
what is happening would happen
i think the problem that people have
bernie is that you're entitled to your
personal opinion about it but when you
say as you just did you don't think
vladimir putin meant to wage this war it
just sounds to me shockingly naive at
best and i can understand why many
people are offended you're not you're
not a stupid man but you know everyone
can see what putin has done here he's
invaded a sovereign country a democratic
sovereign country he's carried on now
waging this war for months and months
he's slaughtered thousands of innocent
mothers children people uh in ukraine uh
only two days ago he attacked a
supermarket with a thousand civilians
inside it yeah the idea that this is
something he didn't really mean to do i
think is for the birds
i wonder if i don't i'm not trying to
defend him in any shape or form because
what's actually happened
is quite terrible
simple as that should have never ever
ever happened and i think if uh
people that have thought about it a
friend from the ukraine and him and
thought or met and discussed it it
wouldn't have happened because he's not
an idiot
and he wouldn't have gone into this
expecting what's happened i think he
thought he'd sort of move in
and then there'd be a discussion when
they saw how strong it was
i mean again i would say to you bernie
all the evidence suggests bernie that he
has planned this meticulously for a very
long time all his activity in crimea and
georgia previously it's all been leading
up to this he wants to restore the power
of the soviet union and he doesn't care
what it takes to do it and he's he's
basically waging a genocide in ukraine
and that's why people found your
comments i think this morning on good
morning britain so
so tone deaf and defensive
well i think if i was listening to
myself in the way you've sort of
put things i would feel the same
but i'd
if he plan to do this i think it's
disgusting and i'm very disappointed in
him
why would you say
given what we've been seeing happening
in ukraine why would you say that you
would still take a bullet for vladimir
putin given that he's putting bullets
into thousands of innocent people's
heads
that
is an expression i'd take a bullet for
somebody you may not stand behind him
for what he what it was i
genuinely
i don't know what he had in mind
i hope
he
also
didn't have in mind what's actually
happened
and i'd be surprised if he did
i honestly believe he sort of marched in
there thinking it's going to be a
surrender
white flag was going to go up and that
was it
but bernie he has no right to do that he
has no right to invade a democratic
sovereign country this is a european
country ukraine it is with the sovereign
it's a sovereign democratic country it's
not somewhere you can just invade
because you feel like it
i don't think you sort of felt like it
did it i mean have america moved into
different countries where they're not
really welcome
well we could play what about erie as
you know i was one of the people that
led the campaign against the iraq war
for that very reason so we can talk
about other countries i think what
people have been shocked by today bernie
is they've seen you come up on
television
and at a time when putin is is at his
most murderous and barbaric
you know bombing supermarkets you you
appear on television and act as his
defender as his supporter to the extent
that you would take a bullet for him and
whatever you meant by that phrase i
think it's caused it's caused huge
offense i just wonder whether on
reflection
you wish you hadn't been quite so
supportive maybe you do maybe you don't
regret it but
i don't regret
my feeling for him
that he's not the person that is being
portrayed
in fact in fairness nobody's portraying
him at all they're just showing up up
exactly what is happening
and saying he's the one that's made it
happen
well i mean you also go on to attack uh
president zielenski
who use you sort of sneer at him saying
he used to be a comedian i think he
wants to continue that profession as a
comedian what has been comedic about
zolensky's leadership if you know all
he's done is try to stand up for his
country and his people there's nothing
comedic about it is it
well this way he's been acting i mean
i think he's uh he's looking for a bit
of publicity whereas nobody had ever
heard of him before now he's talking to
the president the united states and
everybody else
and not just talking to them making sure
he's speaking to them when he's been
televised and broadcast worldwide but
you genuinely think zolensky is doing
all this for self publicity
i don't think he's doing it for so
obviously i was doing it because he
doesn't have his choice
the only choice he had was before it
started but to try to contact
putin and have a discussion with him
why should he do that he's a leader of a
democratic country he's elected
president
in a democracy why should he have to
call a dictator in russia to try and
ward off his troops why should he do
that
well before the troops went in he could
have done that
and i suppose if he knew what he was
going to happen
that would have been the right thing to
do wouldn't it
no i don't think it would have been the
right thing to do is to stand up for
your sovereign democratic country and
your people i think zielinski's shown
unbelievable
inspiring leadership what he said is no
you will not invade us you will not
destroy our cities you will not raise
them to the ground with your bombers you
will not attack our supermarkets our
mothers our children our maternity units
and he stood there in the middle of he
hasn't left the country which many
leaders could have done in his position
he stood there and he's fought with his
people i can't think of a more
outstanding example of heroic courageous
leadership frankly
that's what you think yeah it is what i
think
that's how you've seen it
i don't understand why you would see it
any other way bernie
but simply he could have stopped it
himself couldn't he i think if i wanted
if this is a happen i was there
and i wanted to protect my people i'd
have
got hold of putin and said listen we've
got to stop this
and what would you have done surrendered
i'd have found a very dignified way to
do that because that's in fact probably
what will have to happen anyway
what is the dignified way to to end this
then
to end this
they should talk to each other
what about
about what's happening
well we know what's happened putin's
invaded ukraine and has started killing
every ukrainian he can find i mean
what's there to talk about if you're if
you're the president of ukraine
what do you talk about with vladimir
putin other than telling him get your
tanks off my lawn
maybe that would be a good start
well
he keeps saying this in public zelinski
he's made it very clear he wants russia
to stop attacking his people which seems
to me a pretty reasonable thing for a
president of ukraine to say right now
he said on television yeah
he said
well what's the difference peter knows
putin knows what he's doing
a little bit different if you're talking
face to face with somebody he said no
listen let's stop all this nonsense
a lot of people are being killed because
of this let's stop it you've said about
putin that you you trust him that he
always delivers on his word is that is
that what you think of him
yeah
when did you last speak to him
i'm not going to answer that
but was it was it during the war
during the war
i hadn't spoken to him since his
conflict started right
and if you did speak to him what would
you say to him now
i wouldn't be able to give him any
instructions and i wouldn't want to i'd
simply say have you given a little any
thought to exactly what's happening
from when
you invaded if that's the right word
what to say
ukraine
i mean he's saying he didn't invade it
and he's in this military operation
you know that's complete nonsense bernie
don't you
he obviously invaded ukraine we all saw
it we've seen him we've seen what he's
done
i'm saying that's what he says
why would again it comes back to why
would you believe that then he seemed to
believe everything he said says why his
actions clearly speak to the complete
opposite of what he's saying
did you hear me say i believed it
you said that you trust him and you and
you take him at his word no did i say i
believe
i believed it
well do you believe him
no
okay so you don't believe all right well
that that's progress i think about this
you don't believe him when he says that
it was an operation you do believe he he
waged war deliberately
no i don't think he weighs forward
deliberately
but i think he threatened
and used his
troops
on the borders to threaten
that they should start talking
bernie as somebody who's a as a
grandfather a father
you know and i know you're a loving
family man
uh when you see
children
being
blown to pieces when you see maternity
units with pregnant mothers being
deliberately attacked when you see
refugees being targeted as they try and
flee when you see millions of people
losing their homes having to leave the
country when you see all this
does not a part of you think i got it
wrong about putin actually
he is a monster
i don't think i'd say i actually
remember the last war and i'm sure you
did as well
these things happened there
when england was sort of moralistic
wanted to be invaded
these things happen in war
it's not a nice thing to happen and you
know
as well as anybody else in the end after
a war everyone's
good friends
it's like a boxing match after the
boxing match everybody's loving each
other
i don't think there's much chance that
people i don't think there's much chance
bernie are people being good friends
with vladimir putin after this the
entire international community is now
pretty much agreed with the exception of
some of his allies that what he's done
is completely reprehensible and flies in
the face of of all international law
how many uh russians were there in
ukraine when he had
invaded well they're not the ukrainians
some of them speak russian but they're
they're ukrainians
they were russians well they're not
though are they they're ukrainians
they were all russian people that just
yeah now you're sounding like you're
sounding like putin bernie in the sense
of what putin wants to do he wants to
restore the soviet union and pretend it
was never broken up and these countries
didn't go off and become democratic
countries but that's what they did you
can't undo it it'd be like the british
empire suddenly being restored and just
assuming that history is irrelevant and
that countries haven't moved on haven't
become independent
that is a very nice way to put it the
way you put and it's probably the truth
and i'm quite sure
if you asked him
he would say what has happened was a
mistake
yeah but it's more than just a mistake
it's a mistake that costs as cost an
unbelievable amount of
innocent lives being taken
not only innocent lives assuming
captured completely ukraine what has he
captured country that's been destroyed
right so it seems to me bernie you
understand what's really going on here
and that makes your stoic defense of pl
putin right now so baffling to people
you know you're one of the most powerful
figures in world sport in my lifetime
you have huge influence stuff that you
say
carries enormous weight
as you can see from the reaction to what
you said i just find it completely
baffling that you would think this is
the right moment to say vladimir putin
is a first-class person
as far as i'm concerned he was
right so is he sure
i'm a little disappointed in
the actions that have been taken
and what's what's the what was the
alternative either he pulls out or the
other people surrender
well actually the alternative is you
don't invade sovereign countries
illegally and kill everybody and to say
you're a little disappointed by a
murderous genocidal rampage again your
use of language bernie is is
extraordinary a little disappointed that
he's murdering innocent people every
single day all day long
now i'm disappointed in what
has happened
because i would have never believed it
would happen under his reading
could it be that vladimir putin has
pulled the wool over your eyes bernie
he's not the person you thought he was
that actually he's not this mr
trustworthy guy that actually he's a
duplicitous dictator and now we're
seeing the absolute reality of what
putin's about
well i suppose looking at what's
happened
you could sum it up in that way
so if that is the if that is the case
and you can see that is the case
why would you still take a bullet for
him
there was an expression i said i would
it started it wasn't something i said
today for the first time no i know you
said it before you said before you stand
in front of a machine gun
for vladimir putin and when you said
that that was before the ukraine war i
think what's upset people so much is
he's saying it today
when we're months and months into this
war and the the slaughter of misery has
been unrelenting for the ukrainian
people and there's you bernie ecclestone
one of the most famous figures in world
sport basically giving an emphatic
endorsement to vladimir putin saying
he's a first-class person you completely
trust him and you take a bullet for him
you must understand why that's caused
such a fence
what uh i'm saying i'm saying what i
believe
nothing to do with any sport
or anything that i represent this is my
personal feeling
about putin
the the other thing that you said today
which caused a lot of upset to people
was he defended nelson piquet the former
formula one uh legendary driver who used
the n-word in a podcast to talk about
lewis hamilton in a derogatory way
and i want to display you what lewis
hamilton has said about this and in
relation to your comments
we should not be giving these people a
platform
these old voices are you know whether
they're self-conscious or consciously
do not agree that people like me for
example should be in a sport like this
do not agree women should be here like
it's just
discrimination is not something we
should be projecting and promoting
and given a platform to create and
divide people
you know we're all the same and
it is not helpful
the comments that we're seeing from
these people and
i don't think you know the last couple
weeks i don't think the day's gone by
where there's not been someone from
uh some of the older
uh that have not really been in our
sport or relevant in that sport for
decades
trying to
saying negative things and trying to
bring me down but i'm still here i'm
still standing strong
what is your response to what lewis
hamilton said bernie
complete load of rubbish
really
really
why would you say that
because nobody's i don't if he's
referring to me
it's nothing i've done he should even
think a little bit
his father and myself were talking about
going into business a little while ago
i've got nothing in the world to do or
not i'm not racist quite the opposite
actually
and to say things like that is
completely crazy
you say that but you've defended nelson
pk for using the n-word to describe
hamilton personally in a derogatory way
it's hard to imagine a more racist thing
for somebody to do than what pk did and
yet you defended him he said people say
things
if people happen to be a bit little bit
overweight or undersized like me i'm
quite sure people have made remarks
about that
i'm surprised lewis hasn't brushed it
aside or better than that replied but
now he's come out nelson's apology why
should lewis hamilton brush aside a
formula one legendary figure like nelson
piquet calling him the n word
well i didn't i don't know what the n
word was
well the n word is the m word it's not
ambiguous
well i don't know what it was i i mean i
didn't know
did he said something in portuguese i
believe he used the brazilian equivalent
of the m-word but it's exactly the same
in his connotation it is exactly the
same and it's racist intent he made a
racist comment that is why everybody
uh right now is distancing themselves
from pk apart from again you
and you know in in the same interview
that you've defended putin who's waging
an illegal war you defend nelson pique
for calling lewis hamilton a disgusting
racist epithet
and
and then when lewis hamilton responds in
the way that he did which most people
completely understand you call it
absolute nonsense
not that he never mentioned bk
or the n-word
did he
yeah but
how can you defend nelson pk for calling
lewis hamilton the m word
and how can you dismiss what lewis
hamilton says is nonsense when he's
clearly as
the only main black driver in formula
one why on earth why on earth would you
not have any empathy for him about
having to be called this
stop a second
the question
to him i don't know his answer wasn't
about the n-word
the answer was about elderly people
being involved in the sport being able
to speak
he said we met i gave
a
a colored driver first
formula one and the guy came out and
very clearly
and was very thankful
recently he said this
i pulled things out of south africa
i've probably done as much for anybody
about racist which i'm
anti-anti-aunty
i can honestly say and i've said it
before i've never met
a colored person
that i found i don't like i see even the
language you're using now bernie will be
uh inflammatory to people
because you talk about people of color
or black people but they don't use that
phrase color people so i mean lewis
hamilton's response to that would be
you've got to move with the times and
use the language that is less
inflammatory do you understand that
which is what
good example which is used you either
say that they are a black person or
people of color that's the language that
is used today
well i said that
you said colored people
yeah what color
how can i word it maybe my english isn't
good but i would have thought people
would understand that it's not ambiguous
bernie what he said is a brazilian he
used a word which is the brazilian
equivalent of the n-word there's no
doubt about this it's all on a podcast
everybody's heard what he said
yeah they all understood it i'll brush
up on my portuguese
and probably all the people that heard
it would do have to do the same
lewis hamilton also said an interview
with the telegraph in relation to your
comments about putin
he said you know what you're going to
get with that i don't know where good
morning britain's goal was this was
great and and divide by having you on as
a guest at all
he said we don't need any more of it to
hear from someone that believes in the
war on the displacement displacement of
people and killing of people and
supporting that person putin is beyond
me i cannot believe i heard that this is
going to put us back decades and we've
yet to see the real brunt of the pain
why we do not need to be supporting that
but looking into the future we don't
have anything positive contribute don't
give them any space so lewis hamilton
was enraged that you were even given the
platform to say that you supported putin
but in relation to what he says about we
don't need to hear from someone that
believes in the war what do you say to
that
i'm surprised i mean sorry what
what you showed me just now was
something that
that
lewis had said this is an interview
given to a telegraph today uh in
relation to your comments nobody said
that because you've recorded it and
you're explaining it to me where was it
says no no this is these are further
quotes from lewis to the telegraph
they're not on camera so this is an
interview given to the telegraph
what you said shown me was him talking
and speaking that that was
yes that was earlier this is other
quotes he said to the telegraph
but wait a minute that's what he said
how did he get that platform to say that
and why should he have been given the
platform to say that
so you don't think lewis hamilton should
get a platform to respond to what you
said
yeah i'm delighted he did it
and what i can't understand is why he
complained that i had a platform
to say something well because you could
because you're defending a war monger
vladimir putin who's waging an illegal
war and because you're defending nelson
piquet for calling him the n-word which
you say should be treated like somebody
calling you a bit undersized
yeah
exactly which happens all the time
there is no equivalence between somebody
calling a black person the n word and
saying that you
are undecided there's no equivalence you
must see that
terribly rude
sorry
it's terribly rude to say somebody's
underscore always a fat person you
genuinely think that there is some
equivalence between calling a black
person the m word and call and saying
that you're short for example
well if for example they're black and
they're saying or if you're fat i
suppose it's the same sort of feeling
it's not though is it
i don't know it depends if you're fat
you genuinely think that people
commenting on someone's size
has the same ability for offense as
commenting on somebody's skin color in a
derogatory way
yes
why not it's no surprise to me bernie
your comments this morning calls outrage
and i think when people watch our
interview they're gonna feel more
outraged because they're gonna think you
just don't get it well my feelings of
pujin have only been
my meetings with him
and things i've done with him
so that's my feelings about him that's
what i think he's a straightforward guy
but he's been straightforward as far as
i'm concerned
and he's done everything he said he'd do
so from that
to me that's good
because there's not many people
around today that like
as for nelson i've known nelson for
years i'm very surprised that he would
be
saying something bad
that he really genuinely believed and i
think he might have exploded
over the accident with
lewis and
axel
well there's never any justification for
anybody saying the n-word and even less
justification frankly for someone who's
a is a big figure in the formula one to
say it about the most famous black
formula one driver is it's a disgusting
thing that pk said and what you should
have done if you don't mind me offering
some advice to someone of your venerable
age and experience what you should have
done when you were asked about it is
simply condemn it and say absolutely
outrageous anyone would say that about
lewis hamilton but instead you didn't
you defended it and likened it to
someone commenting on someone's size
and that's why lewis hamilton was so so
upset and outraged
if any if i heard anybody in front of me
say that
to lewis i would defend lewis
without any shadow of doubt but you
didn't defend him when you when you were
when you were told nelson pika you were
booked on the show good morning britain
specifically to talk about what nelson
pique said so you knew what he said and
you defended him i don't know if that
would defend it i don't understand that
well what do you mean let me explain
when you were asked about it you said
that uh people say things if people
happen to be a little bit overweight or
undersized like me i'm quite sure a lot
of people have made remarks about that
i'm surprised lewis hasn't brushed it
aside
i mean yeah why should he brush it aside
lewis hamilton doesn't think we should
even be giving you platform to say this
stuff i don't happen to believe in no
platforming people i want you to be able
to clarify and explain what you said but
the fact you still don't really get why
it would be so offensive
to not condemn what pk said
is what will baffle people
would be offensive to me if anyone said
anything
in that way about me i would defend it
but you say that you're not racist and
you say if you heard someone say the n
word in front of you you would tackle
them and yet when you're told that
someone you know nelson pk says this
about lewis hamilton you go on national
television in the uk
to defend him
and i can't squeeze i can't square those
things what would it take bernie for you
to
denounce vladimir putin and cut off any
association with him what more would he
have to do
what would he have to do yeah
well i've not spoken to him as i said
during this conflict went on
so i don't know if my relationship with
him
will still continue
why would you want it to given what he's
done
i'd like to
which i would obviously if i wanted to
have the answer from him as to why he
actually acted in this way bernie i
appreciate you coming on the show i do
uh you didn't need to i appreciate you
giving more clarity to your comments
this morning i'll be straight with you
like you're saying only a long time i
was startled by what you said this
morning
uh i don't think i don't think you
should be
defending putin in any way and i think
you should be randomly condemning nelson
piquet everybody else has done and i
think if i were you i would look at the
comments
on every single news story about this
which should have been published and see
what the public feel about what you said
and you might be surprised maybe you're
not interested maybe you don't care
but there's been universal condemnation
for what you said
no i do care and i've had a few phone
calls
saying to me well done
a few more people don't speak like that
you've had people say well done because
you defended vladimir putin
and you defended nelson pinkey
but the world down on the on the show
really you you've had people
congratulating you on what you said this
morning
hang on just come on dear bernie just
saw your interview about russia loved it
what did they love about it
madrid asked i just read what was on the
to come up on the phone
so just to just to end bernie you've got
no regrets about what you said
i regret perhaps the way
people have tried to sort of twist
around to make me look as if i've done
something wrong
i don't think anyone's twisted your
words bernie
honestly when you when you say things
like
putin's a first-class person i'd take
your bullet for him no one no one needs
to twist those words they speak for
themselves i am very very very
disappointed in what's happened
with the people in ukraine
and i'm in the process now of putting
something together
to fund
the fact
of the poor people that have suffered
and to the people of ukraine who were
outraged by what you said
including president zielenski what would
you say to them
i hadn't spoken to the other people
but what would your best be to them now
in this interview
if they're watching i'm terribly
terribly terribly sorry what happened
okay bernie ecclestone thank you very
much indeed for joining me i appreciate
it
thank good thank you
you